the last lesson introduced the concept
of arguments this time around we're
going to distinguish noun roles from
noun cases if you're not clear on noun
cases take a look at the lesson on nouns
in the introduction to the grammar of
words let's go back to the example I
gave it to him from the last lesson the
verb give takes a giver a given that is
something that is given and a give II
someone who's the recipient of what is
given we end up with three roles almost
like performances that those nouns play
more specifically they're themed or
thematic roles those thematic roles are
giver given and give II those three
roles become available because we opted
to use the verb give so the verb give
dictates three roles other verbs have
roles to see has a seer and a scene and
make has a maker and a maid now let's
extend this paradigm further there's a
similarity between the giver of give and
the seer of see and the maker of make
those subjects are all agents they're
all doing something so we call that the
agent role there's a more passive role
that's being played by the thing given
the person seen and the thing made those
passive roles are the thematic role of
patient compared intransitive verbs like
I sleep you walk
she ran or you fell there's another
similarity but conventionally we think
of those roles as distinct from the
agent of mater gave these people are
experiencing a state will call this role
the experiencer we might ask what's the
point of all these roles why not stick
with noun cases after all it seems like
we could explain the grammar of ice
slept by saying that sleep has one
subject in the nominative case so I say
I slept and not me slept the subject of
see looks like it's in the same case
while the object is in the accusative
case
so can't we stick with our concept of
nominative case nouns versus accusative
case nouns as we'll see in the next
lesson on alignment that distinction
isn't quite so clear nor is it Universal
among languages we can use this concept
of roles to figure out how verbs work
with their arguments for now let's set
case aside by saying that cased nouns
are qualified to fill thematic roles for
example English nouns that fill the role
of patient are in the accusative or
object case but not a renowned that's in
the accusative fills the role of patient
grammatically they're two different
things
that will suffice for a preliminary
distinction between cases and roles join
me next time to build on these two as we
turn to the topic of alignment
you